[Music]
we brought together seven strippers
i am a stripper i am a stripper i am a
stripper
stripper i
am a stripper one is a liar if the group
discovers who the liar is
they'll win a cash prize if the liar
survives they win the cash prize
this is odd man out
[Music]
my strategy is to kind of find the
person who's using stereotypes what
people assume about strippers
since i'm very in this industry and a
bookworm about it and
know how this works i know what kind of
question i ask just to not be quiet
because i can be quiet
and you know people might think that
stuff we're going to start out nice and
slow as if you know
warming up i have to get on the stage
then obviously
throw some of the heater questions there
so how old were y'all when y'all started
26 i'm 29.
i had just turned 19. i was 21.
21 i was 21. i have to ask are you guys
touching like is your clubs like full
touching or like where can the patron
touch you guys
guys can allow females to touch of
course your female are pretty crazy
not the best stuff but that's not my
favorite um i live in salt lake city so
it's very different here since we're so
religious
we have to stay three feet away from
customers at all times
yeah yeah because you guys would have
such a problem with coronavirus right
because like
how's the american like strip scene at
the moment because it's it's
really weird on stage like we can't do
last dances right now i'm gonna have to
wear a mask on stage but like
the club that i work at the stage is
behind the bar anyway so it's like it
wasn't a lot of
customer interaction or like without the
lab dances on the floor but now it's
like
but he's just on stage with the man's
gone so it's like weird
that was an intense round
poppy she kept um talking speaking
asking questions like she didn't want to
give
anyone time to ask her too many
questions i'm suspicious of nicole and i
think i'll be fighting her out this
round
i think i'm gonna lean towards justin
blair bunny i didn't hear a lot from her
i think i'm gonna vote for justin
maybe lola i don't know i don't know i
don't know
okay so the first round we have a tie
the tie is between justin and poppy
you will get 30 seconds to plead your
case and specifically i want you guys to
focus on telling us your favorite thing
about the job
okay so my favorite thing about the job
obviously apart from the money is i'm a
huge attention seeker i love being on
stage i'm performing i love interacting
with
their customers i'm a massive attention
seeker i'm not gonna lie to you guys
you guys are choosing out australia like
that best part about entertaining
i like seeing a smile on the women's
faces and if there's already some snacks
you know
lesbian gay community there obviously i
like seeing the smile on their faces as
well too
so more than mayor love y'all
not a good case i have to vote for jesse
for that sorry justin gotta invite you
out
i'm gonna vote again for justin ah man
this is poppy puppy puppy please be
poppy i'm pretty sure i'm going to get
rid of
reddit because he looks like a stripper
i'm still going to go with poppy though
i'm just an attention seeker huh
i'm a girl still i'm sorry
the person eliminated this round is it's
going to be may
justin sorry i'm still here
goes to show don't always act so
confident i guess
sorry for the lack of pole work guys
don't have my pole with me
that's okay poppy you don't need a pole
yes ma'am
yes
but at the same time
[Music]
i knew it so you can tell already he's a
stripper you can tell
i am impressed i'm just always
entertained watching mills
yeah there's no way he's not a stripper
[Music]
oh mel strippers make me uncomfortable
oh my gosh
i got goosebumps oh my gosh
it's like a very standard male stripper
move
oh we lost my heels i didn't wear my
heels
with the trolling stuff
okay she's definitely the answer what's
that this girl's bringing out the trick
so i gotta come hard with it
[Music]
she ain't mine but she looks okay
where's davinci
[Music]
remember
she's a stripper
[Music]
okay okay castle moves
this is so hard
i don't know about lola now
[Music]
she looks like a stripper she dances
really nicely
feeling like i'm 2-3 cause you know i'm
zoned
i feel like confused from that round
because everybody was a good dancer
it made me actually suspicious of more
people than less so now i'm even more
confused i think i'm gonna vote for
valentino
sorry i feel like i'm just attacking the
men right now but
lola like it just seemed like she was
nervous which i was as well
it's between lola and poppy
i think i'm looking at lola this round
i'm still going to go with my gut
feelings on puppy because like
she's the only one who didn't wear heels
or anything like that
i am definitely getting voted off
because i didn't know that we could wear
heels
i think mystery is a pole instructor i
don't think she's a stripper i think
she's a paul instructor
we have another tie this time it's
between lola and poppy
this tiebreaker will be a show and tell
go grab some items in your house to show
off to the group that proves you
are a stripper so i went and brand some
of my like
most favorite outfits this i got from
like hawaii
there's like a store over there called
like leather lace lollipops
money making money make an outfit i have
my bag from last time i worked in san
francisco
at crazyhurst you know my club that i
ever got
and i got these bills it was a slow
night but you know
whatever it was the first time we opened
so
yeah i thought slingshot
i know you guys know about a slingshot
oh she's definitely a stripper
i'm sad because i'm pretty sure lola's a
stripper too um
my one thing for two things that i
bought my cash from the night before
last
night four so the two clubs like i'm
working away at the moment
at a new club so these are the last two
nights rubber banded as you guys know
and if you're a stripper
if you know you know they're both
strippers for sure
but we have to build one out i do have
heels i didn't know we could wear them
for the
performance but here's my heels
i don't know this was kind of hard bro
because lola pulled out the slingshot
like you ain't just gonna have that for
no reason
your money rubber bandit as you know we
don't all rubber band our money poppy
i'm using lola because the money she
pulled out wasn't that much money
poppy i'm sorry
that's to go girl i am going to vote for
lola
even though i don't think your turn
votes are in
the person eliminated this round is
poppy maybe because i didn't wear heels
for my performance i
didn't even think to put them on
so what's the most y'all have made in
the night and what's the least y'all
have made in life and i'll go
the first i made was 2 200 in the night
like that was like
oh got the bag that night my worst night
y'all i made eighty dollars and like tip
out is fifty so
i went over thirty dollars bro i was
like at least you checked out
yeah my club's kind of different we do a
percentage base so we don't
tip out like a stage piece so i've never
gone like negative
since it's always been 30 so the least
i've made was like 20 bucks
ah let me tell you about the bro life
for us
lord so i would say my best night was
1200 which was in atlanta georgia
and my worst night when we did a show in
hour i made
seven dollars
dollars and the crazy thing is girls
like oh
i ain't never supposed to bring money to
us to a show i'm looking like
you ain't watching badger mike the most
i ever made was 4 700 it was from
two guys two guys i was under vip
for hours i was like the happiest person
ever and then when i came downstairs all
the dancers like dan you've been up
there forever and i had a migraine so
i'm proud of myself from getting through
it because i felt sick
and then the lease i ever made was 157
that was my first day
and then i had the nerve because i was
excited about being a dancer i never
made that much i had the nerve to take
157 dollars right and i threw it in the
air and i'm like
why would you do that it's the worst
night i had i had to be like
15. um and i worked like the whole night
i stood there
all those eyes but the most i made one
night would have to be like 4 200
that's about it what are your guys's
biggest pet peeves about your job
when people ask to go home with me like
no
never overly drunk girls
yes but because i'm not getting i'm not
getting no tips they
flailing around got
gotta be carried out oh my god you know
it's like actually you guys are too
touchy and they really don't respect the
boundaries even the rules of the club
it's like
bro still have boundaries still respect
us like this is still a job like
so i want to ask has anyone dated anyone
it's a social stigma like you know it's
hard to date an entertainer
or hard to deal with um i'm actually in
a relationship so my partner is
a dj so he's not like a dj at the strip
club but he's a part of that night life
so he kind of just understands it
and respect me and we under understand
each other's work so i'm just very
fortunate to have that i had the
opposite effect i told
my ex i'm currently single i told my ex
i was a dancer and he like uh
fetishized it like he's like ooh do
tricks on the pole for me
oh you gon dance for me felt like i had
to work
outside of work i am single i'm not
really looking for a relationship
but um like customers always try to date
me all the time anyways
guys i do meet they think that i'm uh
they're like oh yeah i bet you're so
flexible i bet you're a freak
like they like just love to sexualize my
job and uh
it's hard to find someone that will also
trust you
as well at this point i feel like the
mole is out of the game
i think i'm going to vote for valentino
this round
last round the person who didn't have a
pose a low low so
i guess i'm gonna have to go with lola
again so i think i'm gonna have to vote
lola out this round because she
just wasn't present in the conversation
i got so
anxious during that round i don't know
why i feel like they're gonna vote for
me
the person eliminated this round is lola
that's all right with me i figured my
time was coming soon
if everyone feels confident that you've
already caught the mole we can end the
game now
if the majority of you have any doubt
the game can continue
give me a thumbs up if you want to
continue the game or a thumbs down if
you think the mole has already been
caught and you wish to finish
the game all right majority rule so the
game is over
if the light behind you turns green that
means you guys have caught the mole and
you have won
if the light turns red the mole is still
in the game and you
lose
oh wow i knew it was valentino
i knew it was valentine's day what is
this
on the count of three can i have the
mole please raise their hand
one two three
[Music]
are you a pole instructor i'm a pole
instructor
and you said it i sent it to the camera
a long time ago
it's a mystery on nicole i was like one
of you guys is a polo instructor i can
tell
i work with a lot of strippers you guys
so that was my thing like i work with a
lot of strippers but i don't stress
would you look at that how the tables
have turned
she was amazing at dancing and those
heel clacks i was like
there's no way that she is the mole i
learned a lot from this experience
especially with the male strippers
and the money is different from men a
lot of times too because they don't get
the same types of tips that women would
get in a typical strip club
i think as dancers we assume that people
assume things about us
but we were stereotyping each other and
we're like oh and i think a lot of us
went off the fact that like lola and
poppy didn't have a pole
the most common misconception with
strippers is that they're like stupid or
they uh high school dropouts or they
have no personality like we are people
and um the choice of job like doesn't
define who we are as a person
you